كلما زاد البحث لمعرفه اسباب متلازمتها
هذانا زاد غموضها لا خصم اجنبيا ولا سلاح
كهرومغناطيسيا وراء المرض الذي يصيب
دبلوماسيين وضباطه مخابرات اماكيين في
بعثات حول العالم بحسب تحقيقات امريكيه في
اكثر من 90 دوله رفعت عنها السريه مؤخرا
وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
لم تشكك بتجارب المصابين ومعاناتهم لكنها
وجدت ان من غير المحتمل ان يكون رنين
الاذنين الذي يتبعه ضغط في الراس وغثيان
وصداع نصفي وكوكبه اخرى من الاعراض ناتجا
عن موجات كهرومغناطيسيه كما انها لم تجد
نمطا موحدا او شروطا متطابقه تربط بين
الحالات الفرديه
[موسيقى]
التقرير الجديد يرى ان الخبراء الطبيين لا
يمكنهم ارجاع الاعراض الى اسباب منفصله عن
حاله موجوده مسبقا او عوامل بيئيه وتعرضت
تقرير لانتقادات ووصف بغير المكتمل كونه
لم ياخذ جميع البيانات ووجهات النظر بعين
الاعتبار بما في ذلك نتائج توصلت اليها
العام الماضي لجنه خبراء مستقله ونتائج
سابقه للاكاديميات الوطنيه للعلوم والطب
افادت بان طاقه التردد النابضه والموجهه
قد تكون خلف هذه الظاهره
[موسيقى]
دفع لاولئك الموظفين يقول وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي
فهي ليست هستيريا جماعيه ولا حاله نفسيه
مسؤولون اكدوا ان وكالات الاستخبارات فكرت
في جميع الاحتمالات حتى في ان تكون كائنات
فضائيه وراء هذه الظاهره لكنها استبعدت
هذا الاحتمال لصباح العربيه هند ابراهيم
واشنطن